i've said recently that uh
reading is to life as life is to death
in other words that that literature
let's think of the remembrance of things
past a massive condensation
of personal and interpersonal
reflections and
relationships it is it is like a
one-dimensional universe or something
that comes to life when it's read
by people at our level of the deployment
of being
but yet we notice that we seem to be
like characters
in some kind of massive cosmic
manuscript
there isn't simply physics ruling what's
happening to us
there's also you know irony
and uh and wit
and the conceits of literature seem to
rule our lives
and this is very weird i think people
like james joyce
understood this i'm not sure it's a
perception you can live with
or do much with but it's
it's very strange i would like to
replace physics
with literary criticism
as the centerpiece of the sciences
and then that's sort of a facetious way
of saying
what we need is a description of the
world that's true to our experience
we have these descriptions of you know
photon
phonon interaction and what happens to
the intermediate vector boson when it
encounters some other kind of
energetic particle the only problem is
this all fits together
but nobody has ever seen these things or
knows
where do they come tangential to
keeping your second marriage together
you know these are the important
questions
and
and science isn't answering that because
it's only interested
in these phenomena which are so low
grade
that they can be repeatedly triggered
and always will
make the meters read the same way
and yet you know love affairs the
evolution of dynasties the fall of
empires political intrigues
tax evasion these are all things which
completely evade
the laws of physics in that way and are
much
more immediate for us
and psychology i hope is
dimly hoping to be able to eventually do
this
but it's it's not clear that that's the
right approach
psychology by taking the ology upon it
lines up as a subset of the church of
science
and what it may be necessary to do is
have you know
a kind of a new aesthetics of being
so that we can talk more about this we
just dismiss it as coincidence
you know say well that's coincidence but
the fact is when you take a person
almost any person and ask them how they
got to be
where they are at the present moment
you'll discover that coincidence played
a large
factor in that well
does this mean that everyone's lives are
guided by utter
meaninglessness or does it mean that we
have misperceived coincidence and that
it is actually the input point
for higher order programming that is
sort of
you could say formatting what we input
into life is being formatted by this
higher order set of assembly commands
that we call coincidence
because it seems to move us around so
arbitrarily
yes i don't know what to do about all
this i mentioned yesterday the thing
about how i didn't
particularly want to change in titanic
dimensions and then someone else brought
it up later and i thought about it last
night driving home
and i've said this i think i've said
this publicly before
but i'm not sure the thing is you see
that we spend a long long time
looking for the answer pretty much in
the
faith that we would not find it
but that there was something inherently
noble about the looking
it was sort of thomas aquinas idea that
the moral life
is its own reward meaning you know if
you're a good person at the end of your
life you don't get a prize but at the
end of your life you look back on your
life and see that being moral actually
made you happy
so it's its own reward uh
[Music]
we are uh you know trying to grapple
with what it would mean
to realize that we could take control of
our lives with language
like i often imagine that
that a conversation is possible which
would completely
take reality apart we could begin and i
suppose that's what these weekends are
all
efforts to do to hold the last supper
to finally get somebody who can say well
and then and then and you slowly realize
you know my god he's going to put it
away
well i'm not that man but
i'm hoping he shows
[Music]
you